Matt Walsh has dropped a Twitter thread
outlining how Fox News is forcing pride
and doctrination on their employees and
oh boy it is particularly graphic we got
that story around the same time
interestingly that uh Fox was
reprimanding an employee who called Joe
Biden a wannabe dictator and then 24
hours later this individual resigned
we're learning a lot about this from
Tucker Carlson but I have to wonder if
there is something going on
there may be an overlap in these stories
what I can say is we here at timcast do
have some privied information as it
pertains to this story and what's going
on at Fox News and so uh we're going to
be able to talk quite a bit about it in
the context of what Matt Walsh has
released as well as what we know and how
we know it